What do Batman and William Shakespeare have in
common? It's not a riddle – just an Easter egg,
one of many in Matt Reeves' "The Batman."
Warning: spoilers for "The Batman" ahead.
A ghoulish gang
The earliest action set-piece in "The
Batman" comes fairly early on. Beforehand,
we see a gang dressed in ghoulish black-and-white
face makeup target a man, but before they can
cause any real harm, Batman emerges from
the shadows, ready to lay down the hurt.
"The hell are you supposed to be?"
The gang members never provide a name for
themselves, and it's possible they only wore
the face makeup because it was Halloween, but it's
hard not to see a few influences on the aesthetic.
First and foremost, there's the mutant gang
that Batman fights in Frank Miller's "The Dark
Knight Returns." They also boasted pasty-white
skin, reminiscent of the gang in the new movie.
Plus, there's the Jokerz gang from
"Batman Beyond," who dressed up as
their favorite supervillain. Thanks to a
brief cameo toward the end of the movie,
we know Joker exists in this universe, so could
he already have some minions at his disposal?
It's also worth mentioning the DC-related
appearance in the gang fight scene.
The young kid who's trying to become a
member of the gang who refuses to commit
violence is played by Jay Lycurgo,
who plays Tim Drake on "Titans."
"I'm vengeance"
While on the subject of the opening fight, those
thugs apparently didn't know who they were messing
with. Right as Batman arrives on the scene, he
lays down some hurt upon being asked who he is.
After laying down the hurt, Batman
responds in a way only Batman can:
"I'm vengeance."
It's a cool line, and it also comes straight
from "Batman: The Animated Series" in the 1990s.
While one might assume the line would
come from the pages of a comic book,
the first time he actually uttered the phrase
came in the episode, "Nothing to Fear,"
where Batman first runs into Scarecrow. At
the end of the storyline, Batman's able to
overcome his fears, and in the process, he
lays down the pep talk to end all pep talks:
"I am vengeance! I am the night! I am Batman!"
Robert Pattinson's Batman
may stop at the first third,
but it's chilling to hear him say it nonetheless.
Jerry Robinson
There's a lot happening during the
explosive car chase between Batman
and Penguin. With so much going on, you'd
be forgiven if you missed a quick shoutout
to one of the most influential
parties of the Dark Knight mythos.
At one point during the chase, you can see a
street sign directing traffic to go somewhere
called "Robinson Bridge." This is more than likely
a reference to Jerry Robinson. He was a primary
ghost artist for Batman comics throughout the
1940s, working closely with both Bob Kane and
Bill Finger to develop many of the central
tenets that went on to define the character.
He's most often credited with helping
to create Robin the Boy Wonder.
He also claimed to have created
the Joker, reportedly drawing the
first concept sketch for the character
– but Bob Kane repeatedly disputed that.
Regardless of who created what, Jerry
Robinson was central to defining the
character with many of his contributions still
cropping up in Batman adaptations to this day.
It's nice to see a shout out to the legendary
artist in the latest iteration of the character.
Nods to '66
Director Matt Reeves is apparently quite a big
fan of the original 1966 "Batman" TV series.
Prior to shooting "The Batman," in 2018, he
attended a "Batman" '66 retrospective exhibit,
uploading a plethora of photos
from his visit to Twitter.
That influence seems to have carried
over into "The Batman." For starters,
you can find a bust of William Shakespeare in the
background of Bruce Wayne's office. This is an
allusion to 1966's "Batman" where Bruce Wayne,
played by Adam West, would access the Batcave
through a secret switch that he kept hidden within
a bust of, you guessed it, William Shakespeare.
But that's not all. Later in the movie, Batman
runs down the side of a building using a cable.
This is another allusion to 1966's "Batman" as
the Caped Crusader and the Boy Wonder Robin,
played by Burt Ward, would often scale
the side of buildings using a cable.
"Hey, who are you?" "He
must be new in Gotham City."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.